hello and welcome to the stream yes that
looking fine I think it does huh I hope
this is going to be a painless
experience in terms of yeah connection
quality yeah I have got a new internet
connection going
and it worked extremely well up to this
point this week worked very well I've
got excellent streaming quality no
dropped frames I've got very good very
good ping times to leaches so I hope
everything is going to work fine I try
to stream the title arena before that
but it did not work like a month ago
because of the it was roughly a month
ago I think because there was this issue
with the storm and had a really bad
connection so let's see what what
happens here I'm seated number 89 89 the
chest will be for a par will be released
on March 12th so a little bit short of
two weeks yeah hello to all of you in
the chat all the regulars they I have
okay so when is this going to start 1
minute 25 it's fantastically strong yeah
I've seen at number 19 and yeah of
course the Magnus is in the tournament
he's seated second at the moment I'm not
sure who night king is yeah he's even
higher rated we have penguin GM and
Rohtang and a lot of his streaming he
often does night king support to be
Richard report ok
interesting how
how we're said information coming from I
mean okay I know reporters from 1996
yeah
so I never Nate could be could be yep
yeah we've got this French account which
could be M V L mean we don't know we
have yeah anyway we will be we will see
what happens
yeah my bullet I'm in the lower half of
this right yeah but you know killed here
there are some GM's who have no rating
okay it's not Magnus I think you you you
tend to play against people that are
near you are seeding and black is not
playing here okay okay
and I know yeah there are many strong
players born in 1996 yeah so yeah
second-place rave
[Laughter]
okay it's tough to to do commentary in
bullets yes still going to try yeah I'm
a little bit better and I've got got
quite a big advantage she already but
okay it's not touristy complicated and
tricky twinby to was probably a good
choice didn't do that it's close that I
can take the area I probably should have
played for mate and this is not such a
clear winner we've been better here to
play for me this is a winning ending but
you still have to winner Jim it's taking
that that is surprising you can never go
forward and I should be able to do stuff
on the Queen side yeah okay that is good
yeah that I want to games I mean it is
just that oh this is a very strong
player I don't know I forgot who that is
and this is mini I think it's very
strong with miss bullet specialist if I
remember this correctly this guy I think
it is yeah
2,800 is pretty high
I've got a very good position though I
mean nothing extraordinary but it is
strong okay 9f5 you will take this 96
will win some stuff the Dalit wins
material still fairly tricky my problem
is against those very strong bullet
players is not the chess
I can play decent moves in this time but
I tend to lose on time when there is
this this suspect vehicles at the end
not good yeah of course I was completely
winning him but he tricked me
yeah that was bad I should have won that
I was just pretty awful okay let's see
what happens here it's going to be
better from a white disposition but
won't be easy 40-something seconds you
know that looks like a awkward pin
ready for Bishop age six here race
pretty quick this person is pretty quick
it's not bad
am i yet blundered yet blundered his
palm and he played well after us
got to go near the pawn I'm using this
of my mind one bad moment and you know
us okay poor tough really really tough
proper business also any is also very
strong bullet bullet player dren master
Raymond it is a tough tournament no
doubt about it
ah okay you didn't didn't see that 97
was good a very good position that I
have here okay
35 it's crazy it's really crazy I could
give my ass on 40th place I apply gieok
now you're playing full scale theory is
cool it's not a particularly great
position and I have him
[Music]
I'm not looking good
looking good disposition it's tough to
make moose yeah for me maybe I get a lot
bit of counter play my get their head it
looks like I could do something here and
I don't see it this is getting and take
your zone yeah okay yeah maybe there was
something
maybe there was something I was Tom
headed my opening position was was a bit
bit too bad this is a good bullet
opening because from black I mean I can
play in billion moves quickly I mean
have lost some and I'm getting into
getting paired with the two four seventy
something that's really crazy
that was a bad opening four bullet game
really was
[Music]
now I can still fight you of course
black is better but still interesting
good some pawns I know I just rupees
seven and I probably even better there
yeah
maybe crap crap it's not the best move
it yeah sure
at least I'm the favorite there in terms
of rating I don't have that too often
here in this event
ma'am
I wanted to do this but he's got g-form
AI doesn't give three is hanging this
one yeah I mean here if you play some
national master and it's just playing
perfectly the whole time that's crazy
996 and I'm blundering okay not good
buying cheap ex is crazy
if you drink you just I mean if you
never drink tea like once in a blue moon
you might buy in a bag but it doesn't
really make sense I should be able to do
this one right come on this is going to
be a wind right that's made
okay I can't win I mean I'm seated 90
yeah this is the thing yeah I'm gonna
buff my seed and I'm getting kicked
I don't like that getting into into
people's theorem that and I have no clue
ah crap I can be happy that they played
badly 95 was already working this is
kind of okay now I need to regroup this
somehow I'm not quite sure how this was
this was helpful I should be and I
cannot do it would like to put something
on to e5 don't manager then he's
checking me okay probably here
[Music]
whoo yeah Finch is not tweeting it
better
oh my god is that tough now you have to
get into the hang of just moving this is
really important in pure bullets like
one one minute if you start to think
yeah you're already already losing on
time probably at least for me it's the
case and it's not a good position but
yeah not good
okay hmm
now that was bad yeah I don't really
handle in London well yeah it's for many
it's a good same for donating re-roof
wanna be nighttime blundering the
friggin porn oh my god always he turn us
against his crib opening sorry not a lot
of fan of this at least it's also easy
for him to be okay yeah this is this is
kind of okay now for me
threatening to window kind oh okay it's
really tough here it's really tough to
do any commentary Oh
Bassam let the 2700 ji crazy is just
nearly in the standings
[Laughter]
this is friggin crazy I know this line
though
I only recently analyzed it it's not
particularly fun why is that okay for
blue rupee eight or something I don't
don't get it
Turing III have to regroup
oh then is checking it's not a big deal
though yeah it looks good yeah that guy
is 2700 feet ah but it's good a chance
you know anything can happen is is crazy
right pickle big cotton is 15.0 the feet
this is crazy
why is this guy rated 2600 here I mean
not saying is playing badly it's just
like Fields feels high I'm going to play
just going to play very directly how do
I get something you're probably I don't
probably I don't going forward she aged
it's going to be that's interesting
maybe I could have taken there already
if 383 is hanging that looks interesting
[Music]
Queen takes rook h7 I don't know
threatening to win the Queen with the
bishop move and the knight hangs and I'm
winning okay okay so Devon are by the
way I'm not going to berserk ever
I simply cannot do it
Oh blundering peace Queen a form that
looks dangerous
isn't there some tactic here come on
there's a tactic
I didn't see Knight f4 unfortunately and
this is probably a draw this guy is 2600
yeah it's crazy I have to make the draw
it's no way around it it's okay now I
cannot do thirty-second chests I mean I
cannot do it pink
it should be quite okay for me that's
more than okay position wise at least
what oh wow that's a nice tactic
[Music]
thanks for the cheer no no that
blundered it probably I would have lost
some time anyhow
we check hmm it looks vacuum not good
for me probably but it looks it looks
strange at least it's not great
mmm yeah position probably Jesse Pinkman
that's from Breaking Bad you know chicks
yeah maybe this one ladies ok night I
have six so what's the deal
am I losing somehow probably yes but at
least it looks funny threatening to take
it back into this position why that is
not time wise unfortunately named and
people are so quick
[Music]
yeah this is tough
media stuff yeah he's got to scram but
this is not so general vote for me think
I'm actually in good shape you because I
have the Kira ideas go for made I'm
wondering before I was so lucky I'm not
blundering before you toast oh I know it
was terrible food like he couldn't move
couldn't move anything anymore hmm
blunder deform who some goofy we have to
play a full scale friendship that's
going to be tricky I know them I know my
my exchange variation but this is not my
my kind of a kind of line that is
probably completely terrible for black
but I have no clue how it is played
come on what what is he going to move
there in the nearest future I cannot
know anything I can check or just push
this push push them baby promote maybe I
need to need a second pawn I'm behind on
time that's the problem yeah thanks for
subscribing yeah I can barely keep up
with things like that if you are like in
the middle middle of chaos what I find
really amazing is that I keep getting
very strong opposition even with my
somewhat mediocre score this is
remarkable
William anarchical I can take it you can
actually take it okay blunder feel it's
not good Jim it's not good
I Scott d5 okay okay so what's going on
here
57th place
okay maybe I can do stuff with the
center you have four and so on
nature III it's kind of kind of funny
that this is all of the Sun possible
I Scott rook t8o our the bad move Queen
d5 and was still interesting I was bad
Wow
[Music]
[Music]
right a quick message not even playing
the Kings in Ioannina sometimes I don't
know how to how we get into some
openings and pull it behind I'm
immediately lost crap
okay I'm immediately lost
who each blank away there are no bad
players here in this event right and
this was unlucky and Nigeria's stronger
okay he gives me this opportunity at
least okay to get something going in he
takes everything else just take every
single bond every single bond is taking
probably probably correctly it's the
problem okay so go here
Queen g-force training Queens this is
this is a problem
can't do much them and I was no me yeah
that makes no sense they will they will
do that boy what what is justice what
doing a year also has a rough time it
seems he's pretty good in a bullet no I
haven't thought about this doing a
German stream it would be fun for sure
but it's always a little bit tricky it's
a tricky decision and half half of the
audience will will complain what a
position him yeah ninety-six that's
really bad this position yeah justice
what was probably overrated yeah I agree
I always had a good score against him
but not when I'm blundering stuff like
c4 she doesn't use
25 Queen g5 Wow okay let's not made
actually but this is made whoo
okay so at least a win this is it
Demetrius is he's a strong rain worst
crazy guy and he gets this pawn back
unfortunately it's not great
oops your slip it happens
hmm okay didn't see that coming
and a-five was just hanging can you Kim
should have taken this huh can I somehow
get an attack here I don't know
came that it's not moving not so quickly
anymore can still play a six year with
the tech check here we go
sorry it was a funny one it was funny
I have no tea anymore that's probably a
disadvantage Carlin is leading by 30
points that's completely crazy this is
not good having fun from the game before
I was absolutely funky absolutely funky
stuff and this is this is completely
wacky and not good yeah um what's going
on yes and we still not really recovered
from the game before yeah this is not
good yeah of course very bad in fact
nothing is right yeah it's just a
complete disaster
okay am i mated maybe but okay I'm going
to smash you anyway okay Queen c3 Knight
takes e4 the funky double check just for
the double check let's do it but I'm not
metered I can take here and then I have
Bishop e3 there should be six this is
actually somewhat interesting not
totally totally crazy
yeah the bishops are quite strong
[Music]
King c1 Bishop b2 made for example okay
so he allows this discovery I have no
time as the thing a check stand made
somewhere probably not I have no staff
no mercy and it was still fun
okay I think it's remarkable that there
seems to be absolutely nobody that can
compete someone with Magnus damn at
least a little bit yeah okay baddest
I'll actually add it looks a bit a bit
weird what I did but I think it still
could be playable nah blundering c6 you
didn't take it objectively I should take
the drone
most before the time the position was
somewhat equal I had to had one good
streak there this guy is not super fast
take my draw here absolutely not
look like this is great but son no
reason to make it wrong should place
your plate 9b3 though you can still uh
try a little of it you can I take it it
has no square zoom I had no squares
yeah
so that's not a nice ending to play
especially not with no time on the clock
I wonder a GM Lou yeah there are so many
GM's like Lucille asked oh yeah I've got
a decent me iqp position here I'm not
sure how I should do it this one yeah
that looks very very dangerous
to say the least he takes it it's made
and where's the Queen going there is no
double check here Knight d60 exhibition
shanks
[Music]
don't see a maid the district's crazy
crazy dangerous but I didn't see him
made I'm now threatening discolored
check and he's could be should be five
crazy okay let's do this then you just
grab this thing yes
checkmate threat 45 though I've got no
time absolutely no time
I completely forgot the time I mean
black God got killed here of course it's
totally killed but I did not really look
at it forgot that it's a bullet came in
essentially what a sick game what a sick
game ah okay I have to also sit
differently
I can have to focus a little bit that
was really too bad you know I mean you
you completely killed black and then you
notice
oh it's bullets yes and then your toast
really doesn't matter our terrible the
opponent's play was before and if you
forget the time control essentially
27 seconds should be okay I just blunt a
visit one crazy okay yeah it was it was
winning anyhow it bit shaky and it's
great to see how many streamers on their
penguin is streaming really nice okay
VTech who the heck is Vic I don't know
looks it looks bad you know what I'm
doing here is really bad and at some
point is going to open it yeah
I went to check there oh I didn't really
see that coming
okay really really odd what I did were
very bad in played oh wait it's not
possible is getting it back oh I didn't
see that coming
Oh 93r know I'm starting to blunder like
a little child yeah ah that's really bad
I went oh I have to fair to focus it ah
I have to focus I shouldn't play that
terribly really shouldn't I mean the
position is good but you don't have to
play like like a beginner really really
hard
what's going on here
I don't like this position that's really
not good I need to play some weird stuff
on the kingside it's the only only
chance probably absolutely absolutely an
unplayable position unfortunately yes
yes yes yes yes yes and no that's lost
yeah yeah it's it's a little bit tricky
with with the openings I get really bad
opening positions but I shouldn't and
this is like what with the time control
I am its I need a bit of time usually to
get my stuff under on the board get a
cold beer yeah you can you can bring me
some but I don't have any don't have BM
yeah I should probably play really
boring stuff like this yes this is my
kind of position on extremely boring
stuff where I'm just better
okay this may be a draw but I'm going to
play this forever and ever
[Music]
puh yeah just just to just play the most
boring stuff ever yeah that will
probably help me
31
that's a bone
I take pawns she gives me pause I will
take them okay he wants to sacrifice 26
not on my watch it seems me yeah yeah
that was kind of clear ha ha what in
sick joke
he just approve eizan I've got pepper
against number three all of a sudden
it's kind of odd which is nice in fact
because there's a lot chance that
actually pair me with Magnus I mean I'm
just going to get crushed but would
still be fun yeah I'm blundering deform
that's the only way to lose this
freaking game ever black was already
pretty much toast
I had an automatic attack on the
kingside that was essentially horror
[Music]
okay no let's not use D for let's do the
boring the boring way a six was already
hanging of course should have just taken
the friggin exchange
with the mate it's that really true I
don't see a major
and it's crying I didn't I didn't find a
media in this industry position it's
remarkable it's sick that's totally sick
yeah
there was no made or I mean I didn't see
it him losing this position is kind of
tough I mean it's really tough to do
that's too bad too bad position and I'm
really really struggling here him 97th
place is really crappy I'm that [ __ ]
shouldn't happen well it stopped the
others they're simply never a simple win
really not I'm not taking a break it
just it just happens I mean okay this
this is going to be a long game
that I'm trying to win
[Music]
is going to see sketchy skating he's
getting a four so I cannot win this game
that's it's a bit of a shame that's a
bit of a shame already a wage he was
played out it was a shame
my opening positions are also far too
bad they're really too bad
somehow I tend to get into bed opening
positions which I don't understand
really why this happens here you can
check me nice trick
I have probably have to make a drawing
yeah and there's no way to get out of
this yeah I don't know why do I get so
[Music]
it is really important to get somewhat
decent opening positions at least this
for me if I'm if I get into bed once I
used so much time that I'm not getting
getting into a game simply
trying to win Sephora it didn't work out
but maybe I can play queen g4 here and
put him into an awkward panel 1964 it's
a great position I should win one of
those good ones
oh that's that's when they took a why I
had to get that winnin Wow what is
always a J like 40 points this time
roughly but Chokin I came and it's
probably roughly equal this pollution
97's slightly awkward black I had less
time this is why I wasn't completely
opposed to repeating
I can straighten stuff myself way is
repeating and then all of a sudden is
not was repetition funny that was looks
really good he blunders and somehow is
not losing immediately
so I've won the Queen it's not going to
be some work try to open the position
maybe get a passive Bishop takes I take
D 164 always tricky he's actually pretty
strong and he's like somewhere no maybe
he joined lane I cannot believe he's so
low it's one of the better bullet
players I think
give me the noise not to I'm going to
I'm stream struggling a little bit here
ah one move in a one movin not I can't
believe this nonsense
[Music]
oh my god
I was just a friggin friggin piece up
not before I cannot believe this crap
someone is playing this joke of an
opening and then I get into problems
that's a complete joke
that's that sick that's sick
yes I can always complain to lose
against joke openings it's allowed
freedom of speech the gist of the
repertoire will be released on March
12th so white is trying to to sacrifice
stuff these kind of sacrifices are
sometimes working they really do queen
d8 coming
I'm Kim I'm trying with the
counter-attack
alright it's a double check and I just
like this that's going to play it okay
[Music]
I'd have to mate is the idea yeah it's
going to have been on time yeah yeah
yeah I was seated number 90 and I'm at
number 90 some however it's it's
probably I'm losing rating points though
this is not good
I mean I'm not going to care about the
wedding but it shows that shows that
this is not such a great event
I'm not doing it
not playing well
could have taken on g-form
which she didn't she didn't do job will
he swindle me or when I just win the
position and I shoot it's the question
look see one looks at seven coming okay
okay so no if I he cannot play this oh
why is that possible so I'm a route up
just don't blunder any everything back
here that sits what I should should do I
saw that the rook is hanging but I
wanted to simplify this a little bit not
dijo blundering too much let's let's
attack I want to take myself off I'm
going to let him swindle
something like this should be okay I
think okay three I can take and then
just take this I just got this chick on
h1 or this phone hi that's crazy that's
crazy and it's a game I have no time
maybe this is what I should do
stone war with white and play some
completely incorrect attack but it's
probably the way to do it
let's try what is he doing here it looks
weird
d3 probably I'm taking I'm threatening
to take on c4 it's not missed people
like good people are strong I did not I
was really hoping somebody would fall
for that
no I play perfect chess even in bullet
great h3 is made
oops that guy defended like like crazy
crazy good I was extreme that was
dangerous I was having threats and
everything no perfect defense he isn't
very quick though I was sick hey I
wanted to reduce the water he defended
everything there yeah
just defended everything GM Luke
is that why is he playing so strange and
why this better of course I'm not so
great oops that's surprising but he
gives me that I understand technically
speaking less is better for white still
love it
it's I thought there won't be something
better than such that's an exchange see
that I didn't see that
yeah I'm stuck at this 90-something area
you have Rebecca Harris sir where's that
name coming from I have no clue so movie
I don't know I'm not the way I'm where
this is coming from
some TV series qg6 still still needs to
work a little bit down
[Music]
how many 200 players Jim probably I
would forget checkmated somehow against
the stuff even though I should have some
ideas myself him I take this 94 there is
no mate sick
take care night if it doesn't work it
just doesn't work
now I'm just not in good shape
I mean I'm I can do better I can really
do better there I lost 100 points in
this I have a definitely better bullet
player than Kings crusher I mean sorry
I'm not in good shape but I'm not taking
this kind of evaluation
Oh keys so I can take here right maybe I
can do this yeah I'm not usually behind
on the clock and the position is pretty
okay
[Music]
okay yeah maybe I can get some points at
least get some rating points back just
to yeah a little bit better so who's at
the top there I'm not not much surprised
and then Magnus is there not so easy if
you'd like to develop from him see if I
can get I'm getting a techie going here
Bishop 66 is a big threat which he
ignores who okay
baron one two three
I feared well fine enough with the
French in the last game
[Music]
I'm a little bit awesome definitely you
will teach hmm I wonder maybe I cannot
take this oh that was a full piece now
one thing that I definitely struggle
with is what in such a the bullets
tournament is simply that the tournament
is so long I can't do that I don't I
really play bullet and if I do I'm not
playing for so long you know it's a bit
of a getting you surge it's got Magnus
got 1600 1600 against operation which is
a bit bit of a bit funny now I'm not
going to start jogging and to improve my
bullet skills
okay some it's going to be dangerous for
him yeah it's also good for non bullet
skills but how to kill him or how do I
put even more pressure on this it was
close en route eh
yeah this definitely is what the check
there was a remark that there's a
difference between mangas playing some
random bullet match or in a tournament
like this I think this is really no
difference I mean he's not going to sit
there and be like yeah but he wants to
win this thing and if it would be
somewhat close he would definitely be
able to open up up it okay to up it up a
notch so what I was trying to say
unsuccessfully okay so you've not mated
this is not so bad
fine let's trade quick I don't believe
in that sacrifice
I really don't
just not shouldn't run into something
totally silly playing this badly though
really giving white some some little
home
okay I'm gaining some points at least
that looks quite okay let me keep the
special please it's not blunder
straightaway c6 physically push-ups here
I fought oh not good
and then he's gotta see it still has
this
it's still at f/4 my bishop had no
square it doesn't work at all okay I'm
getting some point if you get some
points even even some odd point here the
area gets here gets you a little bit
higher in the standings probably I
should just move don't care much about
the games
it looks my move
yeah three I'm just going to give the
piece I don't care just get get
something going there you cannot take
that's a local tribe I don't see you in
ah take and four okay
[Laughter]
there was something I know maybe add
something there I mean I probably headed
wrong
yeah I'm a pawn up he gave me the a pawn
a little bit earlier but what's that
after go back so thank you thank you for
the mission okay kidding getting a bit
cheeky Kenny some places back you can
still hope that you get he's on almost
3,000 bullet hmm he's really he won lots
of points yeah I'm Magnus stood in that
event I saw that Dimitri Komarov was on
Fiona stream yeah this is fantastic
right and Kemara was really a nice guy
I've met him once actually in 2015 I was
playing a grandmaster tournament and he
was competing in that event and we
actually it was a was a pretty long
tournament yet it was me both were tired
so I offered the quick-draw which he
accepted so we didn't really have a long
game and
then we had a nice conversation
afterwards it seems to be a really nice
guy
yeah you said we know I said two draws
the question probably you win but you
have to have to do it first okay getting
a second wind here getting some points
at least he doesn't want to cancel it
seems does not want to cancel
threatening queen-to-be form
it's not so easy to answer
yeah something like that
what's going to have a queen h3 or
something I don't don't really believe
in that
okay do I
this one threatening queen f1 here also
that's a crazy position a crazy position
his queen is saying was check yes
sixtieth place really gaining some
francium nice not noise okay this is a
player position not actually a little
bit better not not much but a little bit
I know it looks a bit strange but and
once you gain a bit of space things for
the follow
really yes probably okay at the time of
quassia everybody will just play on time
and foot have a position that's not
really much going on okay do you do
content on the candidates I have to see
about it I'm not sure because I'm
actually I'm going to be in Berlin to do
commentary so for for Romans at least
and not sure about this what whatever we
will be able to do or not to have to
have to see him
yeah I know it's dry but no he plays it
a little bit strange I mean George is a
little bit so an understatement
so looks like an easy win after all I'm
going to do commentary in four rounds
German language at the location together
with areas or agate skin
Elliot Sawatzky who you probably know
that looks funny okay so I should run
this position
well that I didn't do that that was bad
you know yeah
Black has a position from this crib
opening and he shouldn't okay so it's
it's still okay
I came still it's not easy to win okay I
want to go here so then I can come up
with a three this is much more active
than other ways to cover it I have no
time that was the problem
many played complete crap but you played
it quickly
who oh it's just I was like in the flow
and was not seeing that the tournament
is actually over Wow just a couple of
seconds left so I had a somewhat decent
yeah the rest here was kind of okay I
got some poison unsurprisingly
Magnus wonders wonders again so if we
look at the top standing so yeah the
performs or three thousands and deep yes
more than 15 more than 50 points ahead
more than 60 points ahead I'll pave
isn't a penguin and the win rate is
crazy I added you look at all the force
area like compared with penguin he has
barely any four in there really really
really strong performance good job here
by then and not turbine the Wayne Jones
didn't get so many games in here my I am
really really strong strong strong
strong I hello to Chris thanks for for
the message I hope everybody is alright
at home okay yeah just network is
quitting bullet he really is and there
are many grandmasters some many
grandmasters in and many we have no clue
who they are
hey what did John do oh good a 15th
place is good it's got a really high
bullet writing
okay so I hope you enjoyed the stream
I'm pretty tired I don't I won't well I
want to do any any further games or
something something like that I have to
get up early in the morning and do some
stuff actually I have to get up at
roughly 8 a.m. and prepare some route
endgame lessons yes that's good stuff to
do
ok I hope you all enjoyed the show and
yeah I'll be back on Monday at least
maybe earlier I'm not sure I'm currently
doing the finishing touches on the on
the e4 abattoir it is it is finished but
I have to record the video sis is still
open to do yeah thanks a lot to all of
you bye bye
you